sechs jahre unseres lebens verbringen
wir mit essen würde man alleine die
brote die wir während deines lebens
verschlingen auftürmen wäre der brut
berg knapp 3000 meter hoch mittlerweile
aber ist bei uns in der restlichen
gesellschaft das essen längst mehr als
eine überlebens maßnahme verfasst manche
ist es eine religion grund genug heute
einmal über das essen und das kochen zu
philosophieren
herzlich willkommen bei mir am tisch
sitzen der schweizer sternekoch und koch
weltmeister ivo adam und damit die
ziehen nach chemiker und biologe und
geruchsforscher hanns hatt herzlich
willkommen herr adam kochen ist in aller
munde volkssport geworden sind wir
eigentlich vom ersten besessen sind die
emotionen die uns tagtäglich überlegen
zu geben ob wir richtig sind ist es das
richtige essen wollen wir noch mehr auch
eine sucht es ist schon leisten
er hat sich dieser lifestyle etwas sehr
oberflächlich oder geht das in die tiefe
also wenn wir es physiologisch
betrachten geht es dir in die tiefe
glaube viele menschen sehen sie ein
bisschen oberflächlich heutzutage wir
haben ja oft stand das problem dass wir
tolle die küchen sind umso schlechter
kommen die leute ist über skifahren
wahrscheinlich
die ausrüstung ist umso schlechter jetzt
also aber in wirklichkeit muss man schon
sagen dass das essen auch ganz tief in
uns dann im wahrsten sinne des wortes
aufgenommen wird die nahrung und damit
uns auch wirklich in der tiefe
beeinflusst gesellschaftlich sagen die
forscher das food trends oder essen
trennt so etwas wie ein frühwarnsystem
sind
was halten sie davon es ist das sind die
kulturellen strömungen die gesellschaft
die sich hier auch ein food and
beeinflussen
auf der einen seite hat man die künstler
die sogenannten sterneköche die
versuchen mit viel aufwand ein kleines
teile zu präsentieren und auf dran zeit
haben die industrie die groß und dann
noch größer werden und auch
dementsprechend auch in einen preis
leistung was für die masse dann
produzieren sie als sternekoch
weltmeister gastro unternehmen gehören
ja müssen dieses system welches sind die
trends dieser verfolgen
man wird natürlich heutzutage auch durch
die neuen medien täglich und auch durch
die mitarbeiter durch die küche
beeinflusst was auf der ganzen welt
geschickt und dementsprechend hat man
auch die möglichkeit durch das
multikulturelle da sein und auch diese
grenzfreien möglichkeiten lebensmittel
zu 1 1 zu kaufen ist natürlich der trend
möglich wechsel bei also man kann der
trend eigentlich wirklich von heute auf
morgen ändern und ich denke man muss
unterscheiden zwischen trend im
geschmacklichen sinne dezent in der
emotion von einer präsentation von
messen
das interessant wenn man neben die die
emotionen das quasi die oberfläche des
dec die die art und weise wie man etwas
serviert jetzt sie als als riechforscher
sind natürlich von einer anderen seite
an diesen an diesen grenzen und zonen
dran wie viel hat jetzt das was sie
machen an an der ruhr uni in bochum als
zellphysiologe mit essen zu tun also nur
ganz bedingt natürlich was wir
untersuchen ist wir versuchen
rauszukriegen wie funktioniert überhaupt
dass wir solche feinheiten die jetzt die
küche zum beispiel in ihren neuen
produkten jetzt herausarbeiten dass wir
die wir wahrnehmen können also ist es
denn überhaupt so welche sensoren haben
wir dafür und wie multisensorische ist
denn überhaupt ein essens eindruck wir
wissen natürlich inzwischen das zum
essen geben mehr gehört das ja in der
schweiz wir mal sagen es schmeckt einem
und würde also gab es gibt sowieso nur
das wort geschmack in der schweiz und
geruch gibt es ja eigentlich kaum hatte
es schmeckt ja alles so aber in
wirklichkeit ist es natürlich ein
multisensorisches ereignissen
geschmackserlebnis und wir haben also
ein geruch wir haben einen fuß zu gehen
- also ein schmerz haben wir haben die
optik natürlich dazu das haben wir
gerade schon gehört die präsentation
spielt die rolle aber auch geräusche ob
ich jetzt ob das knackig ist was ich
esse oder ob sie setzen würde gleich
schmeckt
das gehört eben alles drin und hinzu und
wir wissen eigentlich ganz ganz wenig
wie das eigentlich funktioniert ja wir
können zum beispiel die temperatur eines
fixstern im inneren ja weil die
astronomen das sagen aber ich glaube wir
wissen kaum was wie es im inneren eines
zyklus ausschaut wir haben ganz viel
doch da und welche sensoren an
angesprochen werden von diesen
temperaturen zb in unterschiedlichen das
ist das was wir in bochum versuchen
rauszukriegen
und dann natürlich auch optimieren ja
versuchen also optimalere produkte zu
entwickeln und diese sensoren
anzusprechen optimal im sinn von von
convenience ist gar nicht einfach um
stärker zum beispiel also ich habe wir
haben zum beispiel vor drei vier jahren
ein
ein molekül entwickelt das den kälte
rezeptor sind unser nase gibt es eben
ein sensor für kälte dasselbe sensor der
auch menthol erkennen kann deswegen bis
menthol immer in unseren in unserem mund
empfinden wir das kalt und diesen sensor
den kammern isolieren und wir haben ein
molekül gebaut das ist ungefähr über
1000 mal kälter als mentor weil es
diesen sensor tausendmal besser
aktivieren kann und damit wenn ich das
im mund nehmen es ist irgendwie für sie
wichtig stören und obwohl die
temperaturen sind muss ich nicht ändern
natürlich sondern es nur die sensorik
die dann so stark beeinflusst wird und
so kann man eben auch einfluss nehmen
wir verschiedene oder sensorische events
oder auch ein optimales molekül für
vanille oder irgendeinen anderen
sensoren damit bekommt man eben dann
doch auch stärkere sensorische
einzugeben ich habe ein eigenes der
reizworte bereits genannt das molekül
molekularküche schon ein bisschen wieder
auf dem absteigenden ast aber trotzdem
ist das ein thema für sie
es macht ja ein bisschen angst man dass
man sich beschäftigen in deutschland
es ist natürlich schon so es gibt diesen
trend du hast mich gefragt wo geht's hin
diese denn diese molekularküche man
nimmt von dieser vergangenheit von
adrian wehner aus spanien sicher noch
zwei drei zubereitungsarten oder gar
techniken oder auch texturen ist immer
noch bestand in der modernen schweiz
europa natürlich zeichen küche aber ich
denke schon dass man versucht
der trend jetzt und gegenwart man
versucht das optimum am produkt
einzukaufen also ich gehe nicht ins
labor und versuche das beste aroma von
der karotte zu kaufen sondern ich
versuche denn wenn denn der natürliche
gebliebenen bauen der das noch familien
familien technisch noch noch betreibt
und mit mir aufs ausland geht und wir
dann die karotte rausziehen und am
besten noch am nachmittag ganz hinauf
morgen ist und daran riechen und knacken
und reinbeißen noch mit ein bisschen
dreck dran und das ist dann der
geschmack ist die unsere herausforderung
ist diesen geschmack von der natur so
gut wie möglich auf zelle zu bringen und
nicht 1 1 1 1 fertig oder ein
massenprodukt mit ein bisschen aroma zu
verändern aber das heißt erhalten sie
jetzt so etwas wie einen megatrend
vielleicht skizziert wenn sie sagen das
ist jetzt wie bio immer bio
meine große weite früher da kommen fünf
comcom der bauer mit dem traktor ins
quartier und dann kommt die großmutter
und krieg war wegen am fenster warum
zecken ich habe das nicht so
interessiert auch wenn ich jetzt die
belege die ist das gemüse kaufen
gegangen für am abend der kam am morgen
und am nachmittag mit der karotten und
mit dem kartoffel hat dann richtig
gemacht deshalb gepurzelt es hat
gerochen ich habe die größte gegessen
das war die beste die ich gegessen aber
deswegen mache ich nicht mehr richtig
also es sind auch erinnerungen die das
ganz natürlich unterstützen ich finde da
werden das ist das ist endlich mal
wieder verdienen nämlich an die
erinnerung daran was löst die nahe so
wirklich aus und diesen direkten
direkten draht zum gehirn das doch genau
der punkt diese nachhaltigkeit ja so
natürlich darauf für nutzer als
nebenprodukte wieder vielleicht zu uns
nehmen die wir aus unserer jugend kennen
und unsere jugend gab es eben dieses
ganze industrie essen nicht so sehr wie
heute weil da hat man eben das essen
doch direkt vor ort gekauft weil man
kannte eben noch den den produzenten um
die ecke rum hat also ein fleisch geholt
oder sein gemüse geholt und deswegen
haben natürlich wir früher eigentlich
einen anderen erinnerungs eindruck in
unserem gehirn abgespeichert wie ein
essen schmecken muss und das ist jetzt
heutzutage natürlich ein bisschen
schwieriger gewordenen leben die kinder
heute mit einem joghurt aufwachsen und
da steht eben kein
ananas joghurt oder oder mango yoga
drauf aber es ist weder eine andere noch
mango drin sondern eben nur ein paar
bestandteile molekulare luft komponenten
aus dem anderen als eine mango geschmack
dann werde ich damit natürlich in meiner
jugend das abspeichern dass das original
gericht so wie wir früher hat die
richtigen april abgespeichert haben
nehmen wir dann gebissen haben
und wenn ich jetzt wenn die kinder jetzt
natürlich dieses original kriegen dann
sagen sie was ist das denn das kennen
wir ja gar nicht das ist ja nicht das
was wir eigentlich was wir eigentlich
mögen und deswegen finde es ganz wichtig
dass wir wieder zurück kommen auf diese
ursprungsidee wir müssen mal erst wissen
wie die produkte eigentlich die original
edition und dann kann man später
vielleicht auch mal sagen ja gut ich
probier's mal was anderes und was
synthetisches künstliches dann ist alles
gut aber so müssen wir ganz früh
anfangen den kindern ein jugendlicher
vor der schule beizubringen wie ich das
original
und dann sind wir schon mal auf der
sicheren seite da braucht man auch ein
bio essenz und dann ist ja alles im
modell habe das ist schon natürlich auch
eine eine rate von von nicht die
ideologische aussage habe man kann schon
sagen man kann ja sagen wieso muss es
der ursprungs geschmack sein weil eben
dann gehen uns die nahrungsmittel sowie
so aus wir sind zu viele menschen wir
haben die grundsubstanzen nicht mehr
also wir müssen uns irgendwo neu
orientieren müssen lernen wie
schokoriegel mit mit mehlwürmern zu
essen weil das ist das was wir ein
eiweiß produzieren können also im
militär das war ja schön das war glaube
ich meinen track ist das erlebnis wenn
es um und konserven gegen also von
fleisch bis zum brot mit alkohol und
zuerst ausrufen müssen also auch das war
sehr interessant und lehrreich
nur sieht man auch dort dass der trend
je länger das ist ein pflicht konsum man
halt essen musste und ich denke schon
dass das heutzutage dass man dass man
ende sucht was wenig dafür mit enorm
viel protein also wie zb die welt mail
melden oder insekten
das wird wahrscheinlich ende kommen aus
dass man ist versucht konzerten zu hören
wenn man im ernstfall aus passierte also
der trend ist ja nicht schlecht also man
sucht er in der natur nachher das was
man früher nie gesucht hat
das früher ich glaube das ist
interessant weil wir alle dieses
frühjahr mit uns tragen quasi diese
ersten prägenden jahre wie in der
psychologie wir wissen dass sie sind die
ersten vier jahre die uns bestimmen dann
das heißt diese art von von
konditionierungen mit mit muttis bei
ihnen ist es glaube ich der buckower im
römertopf diese dinge essen wir weil sie
uns glücklich machen wieder wieder oder
eine sicherheit geben dieses zuhause
gefühl ist es das also sicher ein ganz
erheblicher anteil aus dass welchen
beginnt eigentlich schon ein bisschen
früher bevor wir auf der welt sind also
dass er eigentlich der sinn der
vielleicht am frühesten in der kindheit
nämlich schon im regional beginnt und
auch funktioniert und wir wissen
inzwischen wissenschaftlich jedenfalls
dass wir als embryo mit der mutter
sozusagen schon mit riechen
so habe das 27 schwangerschaftswochen
riechen wir mitte mutter mit und was die
mutter isst und trinkt und welche
emotionen sie dabei hat das speichern
wir auch schon mit ab mit der mutter
zusammen also wenn die mutter irgendwann
pfefferminztee flick ist dann werden wir
später auch lieber pfefferminztee aus
kamille tee trinken und frankreich haben
sich jetzt alles getestet also da haben
sie die mögliche bedrohung haben ja aber
weil weil die kinder lieben dort alles
zum beispiel honda wenn sie auf die welt
kommen schon das heißt ja die prägung
beginnt schon sehr früh am nachmittag
auch knoblauch kinder demnach also und
wenn wir dann noch enthält das über
jahre an kann man testen das was wir sie
mutterleib kennen das lieben wir immer
noch nachher besonders und das ist
natürlich heime dass es geborgenheit
geben das uns dass wir damit verbinden
das ist natürlich auch die positive
emotionen
es geht auch umgekehrt wenn die mutter
irgendwas hast dann legen wir oder
speichern wir auch diesen unangenehmen
negative emotionen mit dem duft ab und
erhält auch jahrelang an
also insofern in alle richtungen geht
das also wie gehabt für marketing
heutzutage ein ganz wichtiger aspekt
weil der zugang sozusagen zu den
schwangeren hat hat dann sogar zum
verbraucherverhalten
also von daher ist das ein ganz
komplexes emotional das geschehen das
eben wie gesagt aber auch auf wohlgefühl
denn in der kindheit ist also dass
vieles von dem was wir erleben
noch eine glückliche die meisten haben
wir noch nicht wirklich kindheit
unbeschwert und so etwas
und deswegen ist natürlich nahe liegen
dass wir diese zeit eben immer wenn die
düfte die wir aus der zeit kennen wir
sind eben eine ganz hohe chance dass
eben auch positiv bei uns im gehirn
bleiben also hab' mich was für ich auch
wichtig ist ist die ähnlichkeit der
küche ich denke das hat mich geprägt
früher rote prägt mich immer noch
ehrliche klare ein gericht oder ein
produkt ist desto eher hat es die
möglichkeit dass es sich sinnlich und
auch qualitativ ein projekt weil
heutzutage das passiert man verkauft ein
schönes menü vakuumiert mit einem super
aufmachung wahrscheinlich noch ein
videoclip dass das noch verstärkt wenn
man es auf macht nach der mikrowelle ist
das einfach irgendwie carl farben nicht
wirklich mehr froh aber halt einfach
sättigend und ich denke die ehrliche
küche muss nicht schön aussehen die muss
einfach riechen und schmecken service
wirklich der ursprung ursprünglich
apropos videoclip wir haben ein video
clip über sie vorbereitet wir uns
schnell anschauen möchten speziellen
mehrere spinde sehr innovativ sehr
kreativ sehr modern
doch auch klassische basis standard
diese kreative endlich selbst gespannt
was er leistet bringt von dem ich gern
sein
[Musik]
luft wieder durch und vor allem aber es
macht mir spaß
liebe und mega spaß hier merkt man das
eigentlich das duft fernsehen perfekt
wäre das erfunden hätten aber das ist
nicht unser thema diese art von never
ending story sagen zu dem ja auch also
diese diese leidenschaft die sich immer
weiter schreibt oder die nicht irgendwo
gefangen bleibt in den frühkindlichen
erfahrungen gibt es natürlich auch ganz
pragmatische reduzierte formen diese
diese story zu erzählen der
bestseller-autor us-amerikaner michael
pollan sagt es ganz einfach oder was uns
erwartet mit der ernährung dem essener
sagte otto max mosley plants also
ernähre dich nicht so viel und vor allem
gemüse ich dass die never ending story
die auf uns warten
ach das glaube ich nicht ich glaube wir
haben da ein gewisses luxusproblem hier
dass man sich die ganzen gedanken machen
es gibt ganz viele menschen auf dieser
erde die sie sind froh wenn sie
überhaupt genug kalorien zur verfügung
haben um zu überleben und das war ja
eigentlich über die meiste zeit sei
jetzt die menschheit gibt der fall das
eigentlich wie immer damit zu kämpfen
hatten wo kriege überhaupt genug zu
essen hat hätte also nicht diese
gedanken gemacht im detail die wir uns
machen muss ich jetzt irgendwie
vegetarisch oder vegan oder flug haben
oder wie die ganzen dinge alle heißen
und nicht ernähren sondern hat einfach
geschaut hast überhaupt bekommt und
deswegen ich persönlich glaube dass man
eher wieder in eine richtung geht ist es
so dass wir genug nahrungsmittel haben
wie noch nie also es wird auch muss man
ehrlich sagen mit allen möglichen
industrie nahrungsmitteln und
synthetischen und sonstigen food können
wir uns gut ernähren wir werden nicht
krank werden wir haben ihn wir haben ja
den sozialen gewissen gesundheits halb
dass wir glauben alles was jetzt nicht
natur es macht uns krank das ist ja auch
nicht so also ich kann mich ganz gut mit
auch mitbürger oder sonstigen dingen
fast immer über lebenslange ernähren
ohne dass ich jetzt im
früher sterben oder so etwas ja das ist
alles nicht der punkt also insofern
versuchen wir glaube ich im moment eher
uns wieder von unserer weltanschauung
her vielleicht der nahrung zu zuzuwenden
und da kommen eben diese punkte vor
allem mit rein dass man sagt wie versuch
wieder das in meine welt zu integrieren
was ich eben um mich herum habe und ich
muss jetzt nicht alles schon überall
einfliegen lassen das öko grün natürlich
um umwelt zu schonen
also ich glaube das sind wichtige gründe
um solche entscheidungen zu treffen
mache jetzt lebe ich nur noch von gemüse
oder wie durch das auf jeden fall ne
also weniger fleisch isst sich ein thema
und sie sind in der nähe eines
schlachthofes aufgewachsen ich weiß also
ist das etwas was sie was sie
beschäftigt diese industrielle also
komponiert denke ich habe in meinen
vergangenen jahren kulinarisch sehr viel
durchgemacht also ich habe viel probiert
viel gemacht viel gesehen was vom
ursprung her bis zum veredeln bis zum
nachahmen bis zum nachproduzieren bis zu
den essenzen bindemittel texturen und
schlussendlich man versucht sich immer
wieder dort zu halten wenn man bevor man
ab schwebt wo die wurzeln sind und
deswegen das ist das was ich vorher
gesagt habe ist es die ehrliche küche
und die transparente küche auch also ich
möchte sehen von wo das produkt kommt
und warum das produkt so ist und
dementsprechend das hält mich dann
wieder um neue ideen zu holen um das
ganze wieder neu zu entwickeln oder neu
in szene zu setzen aber es der show
aspekt quasi also wenn man sagt diese
ganz hohe gastronomie die wir haben
jetzt von der molekularküche geräten
auch mit effekten natürlich ja das ist
effekthascherei stickstoff ist dass es
raucht ich man kann stickstoff für
texturen zum zubereiten brauchen was
sehr nützlich ist durch die kälte durch
das durch die eiskristalle die sich
nicht so schnell oder gar nicht bilden
ist perfekt jedoch dass emotionelle was
ich meine ist was gibt es schöneres als
bei einem bau der ein apfelbaum hat
unter dem apfelbaum
von der mutter den apfelkuchen zu essen
und nicht mit einem glas coca cola in
den händen sondern mit einem frisch
gepressten apfelsaft klar aber sie hat
uns um diese emotionen muss man
versuchen in den gastraum zu bringen ins
restaurant das heißt ich kann nicht der
apfelbaum wir einnehmen aber ich kann zb
jetzt ein apfelsorte auf apfel kernen
oder apfel haut servieren und oder
phrasen also ich versuche sie auf holz
auf den apfel holz versuche ich also man
versucht wirklich rund um die natur auf
den tisch zu bringen also aber doch es
gibt es schon spielereien also wenn sie
sie arbeiten doch mit zigarrenrauch für
ein dessert mit einer creme also ich das
ist richtig das ist die antwort für das
nichtrauchergesetz was anno dazumal im
tessin eines der ersten kantone dann
wirklich umgesetzt wurden ist man hat
also man nimmt eine zigarre mit einer
wasserpfeife und und und mit einem
staubsauger also ich ziehe da nicht der
ganze nachmittag dann staubsauger und
dann wird das abgebrannt die zigarre das
geld anlegen die 30 40 sekunden und dann
zieht sich eigentlich der rauchte
zigarre durch die sahne die unten drin
ist in der wasserpfeife von wasser wie
draußen dann habe ich ein automatisiert
aus ein gerücht sein wo ich dann
eineinhalb gefrorenes hersteller in der
form von einer zigarre und das gute ist
dieses des das polarisiert das heißt 50
prozent der gäste lieben es und kommen
wegen dem zu mir ja das ist nicht mehr
auf der karte gibt es fast morgen
totschlag und die anderen 50 prozent
sagen wie kann man nur so was
scheußliches machen dass richter wie ein
kalter aschenbecher also schlussendlich
es ist ein zustand der dem natürlich ist
aber wer ist schon rauch nur wenn man
das gegessen hat hat man das gefühl man
hat 'ne zigarre geraucht
wobei das natürlich wieder die
erinnerung ist die raucher werden dass
auch weniger unangenehm empfinden aber
jemand eben dank mal ein
leidenschaftlicher nicht wahrer ist
verdienen ist wahrscheinlich so und
zigarren braucht den eh schon hast du
denn auch im mund hat wahrscheinlich
noch schlimmer wobei es ihm wenn wir
jetzt gar bei dem fleisch waren schon
ich glaube eine berechtigte im moment
in zwei klagen vieler menschen gibt zu
sagen also diese art wie das fleisch
heutzutage oder wie die tiere gehalten
werden und deswegen dieses fleisch von
tieren diesen tieren stammt die will ich
einfach nicht haben hier will ich nicht
essen und ich glaube das hat schon
angewandt zu sagen wir sind ihren seid
so wird man auch zu euch einmal sein das
heißt und ich glaube dass wir im moment
ich habe gerade noch mal gesehen dass
wir in deutschland 750 750 millionen
tiere pro jahr schlachten nur zum essen
ja und wenn man die müssen ja in einer
weise gehalten werden das würde man die
zahlen gar nicht zusammenbringen die
wirklich völlig unmöglich ist und
deswegen glaube ich schon dass wenn man
wieder zurück kommt auf das ich weiß wo
stand das tier das hat ein gutes leben
gehabt dann hat ja niemand was dagegen
aber diese massentierhaltung und dann
dieses fleisch von denen das ist ja auch
nicht gerade die beste qualität die in
kürzester zeit wurden also da glaube ich
können wir unsere gesellschaft ganz gut
mal gedanken darüber machen ob wir da
richtig liegen denn wir wissen dass
biologen jedenfalls immer zunehmend dass
die tiere und das ist ja inzwischen
unbestritten von emotionalen her uns
menschen in nichts nachstehen und dass
wir genauso ihre gefühle emotionen haben
wir auch und deswegen auch genau wissen
was mit ihnen passiert wenn wir sie so
halten es aber vielleicht noch tot was
wichtig ist von jost keller
das heißt wenn ich das mache ich ein bis
zweimal im jahr mal eine kuh also ein
rind ein value und mal ein schwein das
ganze tier wird gekauft und dann die
küche kollegen schaut mal
wir verkaufen pro tag in der hochsaison
um die vielleicht 30 oder 40 kilo linz
viele wie viele hat ein glücklicher und
dann plötzlich merken sie ja das ist ja
eigentlich ein bruchteil aus was machen
wir mit dem ganzen anderen fleisch und
das ist die herausforderung für mich für
jeden koch wenn man viele kochen kann
ist man noch lange nicht gut
also man muss versuchen das ganze tier
richtig zuzubereiten und auch zu
verkaufen das heißt aber auch dass man
sagt eben durch diese verwertung ist die
rechnung des kochs vielleicht
ausgewogener weil der einkauf eines
viele stücks auch viel höhere ist als
wenn man sagt ich mache noch dann die
die kutteln und ich weiß nicht was des
tieres auch ich verwehrte das ganze
die ganze kette dass man dann irgendwo
in eine andere balance kommt als und als
unternehmer es wird genügend fleisch
weggeschmissen weil es niemand ist also
muss man als koch in der öffentlichkeit
auch stellung nehmen und das versuchen
auch so gut wie möglich umzusetzen und
man merkt wenn man dann zurück zum
ursprung will mit bio zertifiziert und
weiß nicht was alles das heißt also man
muss nicht und man muss sich einmischen
machen können und da muss man kreativ
sein und nicht wie man es anrichtet
sondern wie man super jetzt interessiert
uns ja sehr offensichtlich dass die
tiere glücklich sind dass porto fidelio
ich weiß also dass man sagt zumindest
nicht gelitten
ich habe vor kurzem gelesen das ist eine
ganz andere unglückliche kaste gibt
offensichtlich das ist die küchenbrigade
als gibt es in frankreich offensichtlich
sein manifest das jetzt zirkuliert dass
man endlich gegen die omerta die es gibt
in den in den restaurantküchen das
nämlich dort gewalt und terror herrscht
wie sieht es aus in küchen
ich kann da nicht groß was da so sorgen
weil auch dort wieder das hat auch ein
bisschen was mit mit mit tradition und
auch standes oder oder auch die
beförderung meistens zu tun ich habe
mich auch schon zwei dreimal erwischt
auf frischer tat wo ich mal kurz vor dem
kollaps war also spricht vom ausflug man
teile irgendwie hingeschmissen oder weiß
ich dass das ist mir bis jetzt zweimal
passiert warum weil ich mit dieser
situation überfordert war
dh man hat man man hat das produkt was
man versucht so gut wie möglich an den
gast zu bringen man hat der gast der
spezialwünsche hat man hat der service
der vor ort sein muss man das team wenn
dirigent stellen sie sich mal vor wenn
ein dirigent am saxophon ist oder am pc
so und jetzt kommst du mit deinem
gestrichenen c
und da kommt nichts das geht gar nicht
oder und in der küche gibt es halt viele
solche feine zu anrede die ineinander
wirklich was funktionieren muss das deck
aus zufrieden ist und dass man das
wirklich perfekt machten das ist dann
halt vielleicht auch die perfektion
unter streben nach immer mehr oder noch
immer besser zu werden weil ich keine
wenig kirche die die
die jeden tag das gleiche machen sie mit
dem zufrieden sondern jeder koch denkt
wenn ich was gemacht habe vielleicht
könnte es am nächsten tag noch besser
machen
ich werde gerne nach dem geld schon ein
bisschen so das feld abgesteckt haben
ein bisschen ab darauf zu sprechen
kommen was eigentlich passiert mit uns
also beim kochen beim zubereiten beim
essen beim schmecken
erklären sie uns ja mal überhaupt was zu
schmecken heißt wir müssen die ganze
reihe von sonys system aktivieren
also man denkt ja jetzt wenn man
schmecken wird mal an der dann den
geschmackssinn der ist auf der zunge und
der ist eigentlich relativ simpel der
kann süß sauer salzig bitter und leiter
dieses umami
also das ist schon alles das heißt also
die zunge ist eine relativ grobes
instrument die kanadier testen ob jetzt
irgendeinen salat zu viel essig hat oder
ob ein
natürlich über salzen ist oder zu
versalzen ist aber es ist noch viel mehr
wir haben dann noch den nervus
trigeminus an dem wir sehr viel arbeit
ist eigentlich interessanter weise unser
schmerzhaft im ganzen kopf bereichen im
mund hat der verein die ausläufer und
analysiert die nahrung auch noch und der
ist zum beispiel zuständig für
temperaturempfinden von der heiße suppe
auf die heiße sonne kalt ist der kann
aber auch die haptik machen ob es was
knackt oder ob etwas weich ist der kann
alles cremig sahne geht das alles diesen
airbus der gemäss hat also nichts mit
der nase zu tun und auch nichts mit der
zunge sondern das ist dieser
interessante schmerzhaft wenn man die
überreizt dann zum 2
und das ist deswegen ist er auch
verschmerzen zuständig also am besten
kann man es zwar peperoni wenn eine
richtig heiße peperoni darauf weise dann
kann das so scharf sein dass es wichtig
schmerzen erzeugt und da zeigt er
natürlich seine eigenschaften und damit
ist auch die nase die also natürliche
düfte wahr nimmt das heißt also die drei
sind systeme zusammen müssen aktiviert
werden und als ein großartiger koch und
sternekoch tja kann es eben diese drei
systeme in einer weise zu vereinen und
zu aktivieren dass sie wenn sie im
gehirn
da gibt es nämlich zählen da kommen alle
informationen von diesen 30 system sogar
eine einzige zelle die kann man
identifizieren da kommen die zusammen an
und verstärken sich noch und deswegen
versucht er dem koch immer alle drei
systeme zur also eine tomatensuppe diana
türen aroma einer tomate aber da geht
ein bisschen es sein damit er die
geschmacksnerven bereits ein bisschen
salz natürlich die geschmacksnerven und
ein bisschen pfeffer für den cd - und
erst wenn das alles so wichtigen
verhältnis ist dann habe ich denn die
verstärkung das optimale aroma ja dann
kann man eben ja auch irgendwie zäh wie
schokolade und all diese kombinationen
zwischen kaufen stimmt das was was er
hat und so sieht das abschmecken
das ist dort wo die meisten köche
probleme haben also es gibt wenige die
wirklich versuchen die verschiedenen
geschmacksnerven auf einen punkt zu
bringen und ich und ich merke das auch
durchs regelmäßig essen gehen dass wenn
man süße seite scharf schalten sie waren
kalt miteinander kombiniert in den
richtigen verhältnisse dann kann das in
einmal im mund ein 1 1 geschmacks
explosion eine erfahrung gehen die
wirkliche 1 unter die haut dürfen sagt
wow ist das ist das gut oder nein das
ist es gibt wirklich zum teil momente wo
ich sagen muss das ist perfekt wenn ich
essen gehe
bei mir kann es immer noch irgendwie
versuchen das immer noch so und die
gäste sagen vielleicht nachher wenn ich
frage die gäste wie war es wenn sie
sagen es war interessant das haben sie
früher gesagt haben zu sagen
interessant aufgepasst ist nicht auf dem
richtigen weg es war google könnte ich
das rezept haben muss man sagen das ist
nicht schlecht auch wenn sie sagen sie
haben noch nie so was gegessen dann
sollte man das eigentlich archivieren
und nun noch kochen also das heißt
kochen kann uns verändern also dass wir
so einen schlüssel lebens haben wo etwas
explodiert wie sie sagen unter die haut
geht dass wir nachher jemand anderes
sind als vorher
es gibt ja auch gerichte die sich über
jahrzehnte schon fast über die
jahrhunderte uns immer noch verfolgen
ein kleines beispiel wo jeder kennt ist
zum beispiel die sogenannte kubot barry
also die kubanische fahne und warme
hände kalt war sauer süß sondern auch
die texturen noch mit dem neuen wissen
mandeln man weiß nicht was oben drauf
und das ist was das gibt es immer noch
auf diesen karten gibt eine mark und
auch die großen koch legenden von der
kochkunst wieder
schnell war der tunnel rossini das sind
sachen die sich wirklich über jahrzehnte
halten und immer noch in der moderne
immer noch pausen und gerne bestellt
werden das ist etwas ganz anderes
zurückkommen was mir im kopf geblieben
ist sie haben umami genannt also was ist
das genau
also wissenschaftlich ist das natrium
klude aminat das ist also das salz der
glutaminsäure dass eine abkühlung sei
als termin soll
und wir haben ja von unseren geschmack
sensoren her
die sind auch relativ primitiv also wir
haben nicht nur diese nur diese fünf
sorten sollen wir haben zum beispiel nur
eine sorte von sauer sensoren einen von
salzig wir haben nur drei für süss
allerdings 25 fürbitte wir sind sehr
sehr präzise in unserer zunge
verschiedenen bietern jahr sind zu
unterscheiden
aber sie ist fast gar nicht ja es ist
einfach gut für uns zukommt brauchen wir
dazu gehören wir haben das energie- und
da gibt es eben einen die sensoren der
eben auf dieses natriumglutamat
anspricht und gleichzeitig auch ein salz
sensoren diese kombination zwischen süß
und salz die erzeugt eben diesen umami
geschmack der mann dem aus der brühe
kennt aus dem maggi kennt und diesen
dingen und der ist eben auch ein salzes
eben die asiaten vor allem zum teil
sogar aus kochsalz verwenden weil er
eben auch einen salzigen geschmack macht
der küche das ist ja eigentlich bei mir
in der gegenwart sind weil ich sage ich
sage immer das ist ein spitzensportler
mit doping ist man immer ein bisschen
schneller
und wenn man dann wieder hört in
berichten oder was liest diese sauce bei
xy hat die sowas von eine tiefe dann
muss ich sagen ich muss es doch mal was
es ist jedenfalls nicht so schädlich wie
man denkt es ist unser hauptüberträger
stoffen also das hat er benutzt
aber da sieht man auch an den beispielen
glauben das sollten wir doch noch mal
erwähnen dass natürlich das essen etwas
ist was uns insofern schon verändert
weil es ein weil wir diese ganze
substanz in uns aufnehmen
das werden wir ja so ein toller jetzt
gegessen haben dann ist er weg und alles
was auf dem teller ist in unserem körper
hat das heißt wir integrieren all diese
dinge wenn man sich wieder ausscheiden
und paraden und um aber die meisten
integrieren wir in unserem körper
deswegen glaube ich persönlich das eben
das riechen und schmecken das ja sagen
wir die philosophie schätzen die
kulturgeschichte geht oft sehr verpönt
war man ja gesagt niedrigste sind also
dass totilas war nicht ganz furchtbar
und alle möglichen und sagen hatte und
noten unnötigste aller sinne ja ja wie
manu erkannt oder sowas aber das ist
natürlich nicht wahr weil es ist der
einzige sinn den wir aktiv betreiben
müssen
schmecken und riechen müssen wir aktiv
tun wir müssen die wir müssen atmen
sonst würde man nichts schmecken riechen
wir müssen was in den mund stecken
das wird man nicht schmecken wir können
ganz passiv sitzen und können die
lichtwellen und die schallwellen auf uns
einwirken lassen aber nicht die und wir
nehmen den ganzen stoff in den körper
auf und deswegen glaube ich dass das ein
sinn ist er uns stark verändert wie kaum
ein anderer eigentlich auch wirklich
körperlich verändert ist hängt davon ab
was ich esse wie mein körper zusammen
gebaut ist und aussehens ist wir sind
was wir essen ja man ist was man isst ja
ja und aber sie haben in einem kochbuch
geschrieben dass die nase eine lügnerin
sei kann gut sein ja aber auch die augen
können die verarschen
auch die ohren und augen marktbericht
das richtige also man kann natürlich
sich schnell mal verzaubern lassen durch
ein duft durch ein essenzen die nase ist
eine lügnerin
schauen wir doch das mal bei den
menschen an jetzt sieht man dann
hübschen mann hübsche dame die ist schön
geschminkt und die hat ein paar für an
sich vovo einem verzaubert das heißt
noch nicht dass die frau oder diesen
mann ein 1 1 eine persönlichkeit ist und
die passende partnerin fürs leben ist
aber durch die nase kann man sich leiten
lassen was manchmal auch gefährlich ist
und das ist in der küche genau das
gleiche aber dann werden wir eigentlich
erst dort wo ich eigentlich hin wollte
ein bisschen beim sex oder sollen wir
sagen
essen ist ein jahr von
ersatzbefriedigung das wissen also alle
jetzt könnte da aber das aphrodisiakum
ich hab das wort geschafft kann
natürlich quasi dass die die die die
verschränkung zwischen den beiden
angelegenheiten der erotik der
sinnlichkeit wirklich zueinander führen
in beiden richtungen also in allen
richtungen also da ist zum einen ist
natürlich das essen an sich schon ein
sinnlicher vorgang das heißt ich nehme
was einem mund
die normalerweise vielleicht beim küssen
tun hast ja oft auch sagen ja man hoffen
dass wir küssen uns in dem wir etwas an
ladung aufnehmen wir küssen uns selbst
quasi ja das ist dieses sinnliche
empfinden und wir haben ja die kirche
auch ganz tolle tolle tricks auf lager
das auch die die produkte die sie
produzieren eben auch einen sinnlichen
haptischen eindruck machen dass er also
auf mund zerschmilzt oder das ist etwas
rundes etwas an der oberfläche was
tolles ist also es ist ein von texturen
die textur leser ein erotisches
vergnügen und es können natürlich auch
die inhaltsstoffe seien in dem essen die
uns dann zusätzlich natürlich noch
erotisierend aphrodisierend und da gibt
es inzwischen eine ganze reihe
wissenschaftlicher daten und schokolade
ist er einer der der ein erster stelle
zu nennen denn produkte dass uns der
sehr viele erotisierende ja hormone im
körper oder auch stoffe im körper
produziert und uns damit eben auch ja
diese sinnlichkeit erzeugt ist das mache
ich jetzt wenn ich eine dame habe und
die hat nicht gerne schokolade
deswegen denke ich ist auch wichtig das
auge isst mit das hat für mich ein
bisschen diesem aphrodisierend hat das
zu tun wenn man in die werbung schaut
wenn wenn ein herr oder eine dame eine
kirche ist oder eine banane in eine
banane bei ist dass sie natürlich so
bilde mit einer schönen lippe nach
aufgenommen wo dann schon was auch mit
fußball zu tun hat also das auge isst
mit das verführerische outfit man
versucht etwas zu stylen wo man schon
mal sagt waters ist schon schön das will
ich kann ich ja gar nicht essen und wenn
man sagen gegessen hat und noch gut war
dann hat man nicht nur diese sind da
sondern auch diese da und das ist schön
aber dass das können sie ein bisschen
wie bei der pornografie wenn man sagt
also wir sind eigentlich in einer
übersexualisierten gesellschaft für
diese diese dieses bombardement
funktioniert und auf der anderen seite
sind wird sie sind ist ein schlanker
kochs ist also das werde jetzt heißen
also offensichtlich diszipliniert in
ihrer eigenen küche dass wir in dieser
in diesem körper disziplin skeet auch
drin stecken und dass da irgendwo eine
eine spannung ist zwischen dem
eigentlich gehen lassen sich gegen
genießen
dazu gehören zu schlemmen und denn den
reizen die auf uns einstellen
ich merke es auch wenn ich wenn ich
eingeladen bin familiär eingeladen bin
und da wird wirklich noch mit seinem
wissen wirtschaftlichkeit kochen dann
bot zum beispiel mit kartoffelstock
kartoffelstock mit richtig genügte den
es doch was schön ist und was gut so nun
da ist man isst man isst man und das ist
das ist das ist eine eine übersättigung
nachher das heißt warum bin ich nicht
dick das heißt wenn man in der küche
natürlich mit den essenzen nicht mit
diesen essenzen sondern mit der
natürlichen essenzen mit den barfuß mit
den gewürzen ein bisschen integriert und
experimentiert dann hat man auch bei
einer suppe vielleicht noch eine decke
oder nach 213 ist es gut da muss was
neues kommen sonst ist man überfordert
und das ist bei der beide hausmannskost
ob ich mich selber nicht hingehe und
caron
da könnte ich kiloweise essen aber wenn
ich das machen würde regelmässig dann
würden die kieler auch definitiv ange
haften bleiben und ich denke dass in den
modellen ist es auch so dass man
versucht weniger ist mehr
einige kollegen haben natürlich schon
durch einen umfang von ihnen erwartet
dass sie selber der beste gast sind von
innen
aber ich glaube wenn eben das essen
schon mal zu viel ist um es
interessieren sie zu bringen ist es
sowieso schon nicht gut dann also mit
sehr vollen bauch und völlig voll
gefüttert ist glaube ich das alles dann
nicht mehr so tolle und du bist diese ja
wir schaffen ja alle sehr viele menschen
schwanken so zwischen dieser adipösen
sozusagen fresslust und irgendwelchen
diätetischen versorgungs geschichten und
manche sind da dazwischen die einen sind
anderen oder anderen extrem und deswegen
glaube ich dass jetzt auch
nahrungsmittel gibt die natürlich auch
aphrodisierende wirkung haben
diskutieren wir in der wissenschaft ja
immer wieder darüber woher das kommt und
meistens nehmen uns dann die anleihen
aus dem tierreich also so was wieder zu
viel zum beispiel da gibt es ja
das ist ja roma des gipfels ist ein
stoff heißt andere szenen und er ist
eben gleich für sexuallockstoff des
schweines also der bericht auch so
ähnlich und er produziert ist ein duft
um eben dann wenn er wendet die sauen
trägt dann fällt die in so eine art
duldungsstarre und dann kann er mit
ihrer machen was er will und sie die
trüffel weg die sauen und die drittel
weckt ist also wir haben sogar diesen an
diese roma in unserem körper das heißt
die männer haben das wir haben axel
schweiß und das ist ja auch mit der
grund warum man die schweine eben nehmen
kann zum zu versuchen weil jemand denkt
da ist der prinz vergraben da unten drin
und das ist eben wo es vorüber sagt das
ist ab reduzieren weil das könnt ihr
könnt eben ein anziehen pheromon seien
bei uns und alle stoffe wurde es
vorkommt trüffel im sellerie und solchen
stoffen die finden wir immer dann
aphrodisierenden stoffen aber deswegen
ist das essen an sich natürlich nicht
nur von außen sondern auch vielleicht
von inhaltsstoffen etwas was uns
tatsächlich anregte anwender aber steckt
steckten diese stoffe in den parfums die
gekauft für die das ist was anderes also
muss es kaum dafür moschusochsen das
jahren tier dass das produziert aber
dieses anders den lohn ist der titel
also mal das klassische trüffel aroma so
wie man es eben nicht so schwarz dass
man zwar normal
das ist dieser teufel der den benutzer
eben auch das schwein oder deswegen
glaubt man eben dass das bei uns weil
wir eben auch riechen können und frauen
sogar diesen duft wenn wir männer ihn
abgeben in unterschiedlich bewerten
abhängig von ihrem zyklus also wenn sie
denn gerade befruchtung sind während des
sprungs finden sie diese stufe la loma
sehr viel angenehmer als sonst man
könnte also theoretisch mit der frau zum
essen geht ihr sogar sagen je nachdem
wie sie die dürfen wir gerade geliebt in
welchem zyklus phase ist ich glaube
befindet zum beispiel haben sie in tests
nicht außen hat mithilfe gegessen haben
ja etwas was das was wir jetzt immer
permanent streifen ist quasi die die
frage des luxus und sie haben es ist
unser luxusproblem über diese dinge
überhaupt zu philosophieren
für die meisten menschen so viele
menschen und in der geschichte sowieso
war es einfach mal leben zu halten
als als erster zweck jetzt wenn man uns
so reden hört und so ist es natürlich
ist eine art von selbst verstehen ist
das essen zubereitung von
nahrungsmitteln eine große
kulturleistung ist und das ist wenn man
ihnen zuhört aus der wissenschaftlichen
perspektive eine unglaubliche
komplexität dahinter steckt die sowieso
einmal sagt es ist nichts einfach es ist
nicht simples oder sie haben erkannt
widerlegt und gesagt das ist nicht der
fall als der ammersee ist eigentlich
einer der wichtigsten jetzt haben wir so
ein beispiel und sie haben einen schönen
ist ja mal geschrieben über schokolade
also wie kann man anhand von schokolade
diese komplexität auf tun was da alles
drin steckt und sie dürfen so gerne
nehmen ich glaube da der hauptpunkt ist
natürlich dass wir in der schokolade
zucker drin haben und zucker es eben
etwas wo wir menschen von der leyen von
der evolution seite her brauchen also es
ist sogar so dass wir uns dazu kempf in
dung in den lebensjahren verändern die
ersten vier fünf sechs lebensjahre
wissen wir dass unser zucker sensoren im
mund zum beispiel gar nicht so besonders
stark ansprechen so dass wir möglichst
viel lob bekommen es wirklich viel
zucker nehmen damit wir da diesen ganzen
zucker bedarf für das würde das wachstum
gelegen bitterrezeptoren es umgekehrt
zum beispiel die sind wahnsinnig
empfindlichen der jugend so mögen wir
den ersten jahren liegt was bitte ist
denn mögen den kaffee und spinat und all
diese dinge eher nicht also insofern hat
schokolade natürlich sehr viel zucker
damit geht schon an aber es sind eben
auch inhaltsstoffe die die findet am
ihnen ist zum beispiel ein stoff der
eben bei verliebten auch freigesetzt
wird wenn man verliebt ist im blut der
wird über die schokolade mit aufgenommen
und wir wissen natürlich dass wenn ich
eben schokolade wirklich liebe ja dieses
süße und den zucker das dann eben auch
ein glücksgefühl steigt also man kann
zeigen dass beim schokolade essen das
belohnungszentrum im gehirn reagiert und
wenn das reagiert dann schüttet das
belohnungszentrum hormone aus vor allem
serotonin aber auch oxytocin ob sie so
zu sehen ist das hormon das
kuschelhormon das wird immer dann
ausgeschüttet werden mütter ihre kinder
im arm haben und so etwas soll wenn
verliebte sich im arm haben das heißt
also man kann wirklich zeigen dass mit
schokolade erst eine ganze komplex
ja verhaltenskodex vorgebracht wird und
damit natürlich auch uns wirklich glaube
ich ein aus vielen molekularbiologischen
sich tatsächlich glücklich kites gefühl
entsteht aber das haben sie
wahrscheinlich schokolade macht
glücklich ja das macht wirklich aber
andere natürlich lieber wein glück wäre
oder andere dinge als ist nicht so dass
jeden schuh preise die vor allem der
zucker der glücklich macht dann könnte
man auch mit anderen produkten nehmen ja
du bist ja in vielen böden sowie zucker
drin ja also patches irgendwie 20
prozent zucker und alles was wir so
üblicherweise was kinder und erwachsene
lieben hat eben sehr viel zucker
wenn wir die die menschheitsgeschichte
noch einmal bemühen werden und sagen
jetzt was uns als menschen ausmacht ist
ja einerseits als wir allesfresser sind
ist es wirklich das oder ist es dass wir
feinschmecker sind dass wir eben genau
was unsere betriebe dermaßen verfeinern
können das ist das ist eine
kulturleistung märz hinein sagte als ich
auf jeden fall eine kulturleistung auch
das kochen also ich muss immer wieder
sagen ich bin ja auch präsident akademie
der wissenschaften in deutschland zahlen
und ich versuche immer und wir sind die
einzige akademie der wissenschaften in
deutschland die auch die künste unter
einem dach hat also wie sich alle
wissenschaften und der künste das heißt
wir haben die ganzen maler die berühmten
maler und die bildhauer und die musiker
und ich ärgere mich immer wenn ich meine
kollegen nicht überzeugen kann das
eigentlich auch kirche und parfümeure da
rein gehören denn ich glaube dass wenn
jemand ein paar kreiert aus er hat 5.000
10.000 verschiedene duftstoffe zur
verfügung und macht daraus eine
komposition die noch nie einen menschen
nase vorher gerochen hat die einfach
fantastisch ist oder wie sie geschrieben
haben
was man essen kreiert das ein dinge
zusammengestellt wo einfach beim anderen
menschen ein irgendwie explosion erfolgt
es ist noch nie in dieser weise an
anderen menschen gelungen so etwas zu
machen ist es für mich genauso und kunst
künstler und ein kunstwerk wie wenn ich
ein bild mario denne symphonie
komponieren und es ist wirklich schade
dass wir das nicht sagen uns mehr
bewusst machen welche kunst das erst
nicht mehr erst kultur sondern auch wenn
ein kochkunst existiert geben etwas
sperrig das ist ein wichtiges thema was
mich sehr stark prägt in den letzten
jahren man versucht sich zu überlegen
was passt zusammen und es gibt natürlich
auch dass das dass das erwiesene was
zusammen passt und was nicht aber
schlussendlich geht das auch ganz
einfach ein beispiel saisonal einkaufen
und versucht doch nun mal alles was die
gleiche farbe haben miteinander
kombinieren und man merkt plötzlich man
kann das sein und dann merkt man
plötzlich erbse und minze kennt man ja
ist ja nichts neues aber man merkt dass
zb auch im messebereich aber karton mit
kiwi und till plötzlich ganz was
interessantes ist dort auf avocado kiwi
und dill und obendrauf noch ein bisschen
pistazie zb und da merkt man plötzlich
die kombination die kiwis avocado geld
als wenn man es kopiert merkt man
plötzlich man hat irgendwie was im mund
was man noch nicht so im süßen zustand
gegessen hat aber total überrascht und
das sind so die aha effekte
überraschungseffekte wo in der
sterneküche finde ich ein muss ist jetzt
ich kann mir vorstellen das was sie
gesagt
die akademie der wissenschaften wenn man
sagt es gibt natürlich vielleicht auch
ein philosophisch tradiert distanz
gegenüber dem essen und also seit platon
und sie haben das aufgezählt also man
klaut die idee dieser domäne nicht
wirklich es gibt harald leben der
deutsche autor der sich als gasthof
bezeichnet und gesagt es gibt zu wenig
in der geschichte castro zu rufen ein
paar wenige gibt es beruft sich auf
nietzsche und und erzählt dann quasi und
das wäre unser beispiel hier dass die
wahrheit auf seine art von footprint sei
also die wahrheit ist er eine wurst als
ein viele würden sie das auch so
beschreibt ja weil die wurst hat erstens
mal zwei enden das heißt nicht dass es
richtig war wichtig aber schon seit ich
hoffe dass da rein kommt weil wenn man
selber bewusst macht
als dann mettmann es muss nicht wie eine
selber sein war ein drittel wasser ist
ein drittel fett und ein ritterschlag
schnitte das muss nicht sein aber wenn
man sich mit dem thema auseinandersetzt
merkt man es braucht gewürze es braucht
die sogenannten geschmäcker salz zucker
was sie gesagt haben dass umami
es braucht fed transportmittel für den
geschmack und entsprechend das richtige
verhältnis von fleisch dass die wurst
auch im mund dementsprechend entweder
vergeht harmoniert oder dann wirklich
fleißig ist und du willst noch mehr
essen untersucht vergnügen dann das für
das ganze team parat oder die ganze saal
sitzen nachher hinein annimmst und das
ist das ist wirklich nicht der
wissenschaft sondern wurde ist eine eine
eine haut eine hülle die das ganze
zusammen jetzt kunst das wäre dann das
zweite gewesen weil es mich interessiert
es fühlen sie sich als künstler
es kommt darauf an
wenn ich essen kreiere ja wenn ich esse
produziere als dienstleister und wenn
nicht schauen dass alles funktioniert
und der gast bereit ist so viel geld
auszugeben aus unternehmen aber im
inneren muss man schon kreativ und
künstlerisch sein für das man das essen
mit begabung kreieren kann dass der gast
sagt so was ist wirklich interessant gut
speziell und noch habe ich noch nie
gegessen jetzt kunst seit anfang jahr
hat im 19
darunter auch etwas mit radikalität zu
tun oder wenn man sieht wie weit seid
man etwas
es gibt die neue nordische küche wo man
nicht weiß ich der steine und moos mit
einbaut und wo wir es für sie eine art
von grenze wo die nahrungsaufnahme
zurückgeht und und gegen etwas sich
verselbstständigt also ich denke
künstler ich möchte das schon noch
klarstellen ich bin nicht ein künstler
weil ein künstler ist im food-bereich
jemand der seinen weg noch nicht
gefunden hat das heißt sondern auch dem
motto wenn was nicht gut ist dann mache
ich ein bisschen soße darüber und dann
muss es so sein das ist wie bei der
kunst wenn ich jetzt ein bild mache ich
bin ein bisschen
jetzt so nicht sony ich mache das jetzt
rot oder gelb und dann kann ich das
verkaufen wenn ich ein name habe aber
das stimmt für mich so und beim essen
ist es nicht so es muss ja für die
gesellschaft noch nachvollziehbar sein
was ich da kreiert habe und deswegen ist
es für mich schon noch wichtig dass man
sich nicht in einem trent verirrt und da
plötzlich dann ausstirbt da gibt es ja
auch viele weil man zu viel aufwand an
den tag bringen muss führt dass das
gericht so ist wie man denkt aber der
gast ist noch nicht zufrieden und ist
nicht bereit das zu bezahlen also man
muss schon versuchen zurück zur wurzel
packt das richtige produkt in den
vordergrund zu stellen ist wie ein krimi
einem james bond das richtige produkt
für das bezahlte geld das ist der bund
dann habe ich die liebhaberin dann habe
ich der bösewicht und dann vielleicht
noch das auto ist ein bisschen marketing
macht oder und das zusammen muss in den
richtigen verhältnissen sein dass der
gast das bezahlt was er will und das
auch essen kann er löst nicht wer jetzt
dass der gastrokritiker nein also der
gastrokritiker ich habe das vergnügen
dass die regelmäßig kommen und auch das
vergnügen dass ich sie zum glück nicht
kenne
aber weil ich bin ich mir einig mit
erdgas und man erkennt sie durch nämlich
an
nein ich denke bei mister so sehr
servieren meistens zu zweit kommen
alleine das ist vielleicht auch
auskosten technischen gründen soll
dort könnte man annehmen wenn sie noch
deutsch sprechen obwohl auch das ist
mittlerweile international das könnte
vielleicht ein test sein aber es gibt
die texte die dann sich bemerkbar machen
nach dem essen und sagen wir haben
getestet stellen noch ein paar fragen
und dann ist so dass sie meistens die
profis das sind die die selber wirklich
da rauskommen was da gegessen werden
dann gibt es viele viele leute die insel
kommen auch blogger die eigentlich keine
ahnung haben was sie gegessen haben und
dann dann auch noch lange frage du das
fahrzeug genau wie hast du das gemacht
und übrigens welches gemüse war ist das
und das liest man dann 122 gericht da
muss ich sagen da fällt manchmal
vielleicht ein bisschen dass der
professionelle hintergrund für mich muss
ein gastrokritiker nicht in erster linie
journalist sein sondern wut auf ihn und
zwar auch bei essen
aber es ist etwas was man lernen kann es
ist erst mal lernen ich muss ja also das
ist etwas was man tatsächlich trainieren
kann üben kann nicht jeder hat
wahrscheinlich dann am schluss die
gleiche perfektion um das am ende auch
in der höchsten ausprägung zu lernen und
zu verstehen und so zu riechen
aber es ist doch vollkommen klar dass
natürlich eine reine übungs geschichte
ist also wir haben insgesamt 350
verschiedene zelltypen in der nase und
und aus denen produziert jedes gericht
ein bestimmtes aktivierungsmuster also
mit einem mit einer wurst werden
irgendwie 50 dieser zelltypen aktiviert
und die muss jetzt mal auswendig lernen
dass es eine salami isst ja und wenn ich
jetzt eine andere serie hat es dann
werden vielleicht auch irgendwie 50
ein bisschen andere aktivieren die muss
ich alle auswendig kann ich sagen dass
ich alphabet a350 buchstaben und die
duft wörter sind bis zu 100 buchstaben
lang und die muss ich in meinem kopf aus
mir gern um eben auch zwei weine jetzt
einen traminer von einem berliner
unterscheiden zu können
da muss ich wirklich mindestens 80
dieser kommen nach dieser buchstaben
lernen und überlappen sich zum teil aber
jede wand sagt er hat eben mit der
andere
und deswegen ist es reine übungssache
glaubt viele lernen dass auch nie
und da sind vielleicht lernen und das
ist halt das große problem und würde ich
auch jedem laien sagen er soll sich
nicht darum kümmern wenn irgendwann zum
jedem erzählt aber da jetzt diese diese
pflaume oder diese brombeere schmeckt
und im abgang noch irgendeine eine
himbeere das alles vergessen wenn eben
die airline schmeckt ist das wichtigste
und nicht ob er jetzt jede diesen heraus
schmeckt oder an der politischen willkür
sich an das heißt wenn der chef des
service ist das licht aus drehen würde
mitten im am abend das dass das völlig
interessanter ist ergebe als lebender
kostüms mit der schlimmste was man einem
bein zum nie antun kann also es gibt
sogar die zehn bekanntesten so in paris
erst mal blind verkostet die konnten
nicht mal in weiß von rotwein
unterscheiden wenn es eine ähnliche
sorte ist ja da wir hatten sieben mit
ihrer mit ihrer forschung dazu beitragen
das nicht hat damit also es ist mir
einfach viel zu schwierig also ich ja
immer braucht viel mehr informationen um
eben einen bestimmten weinen der zb zu
erkennen
nur die als nur ein glas hat in
blindverkostung ich muss ihn schon in
eine schublade irgendwo in meinem gehirn
erst mal ein hinweis kriegen soll jetzt
in der lieblichen schublade schauen oder
zumindest weil die gegend kennen
sonst habe ich einfach so viele
eindrücke wo ich gerade jetzt raus
bringen kann und somit handle und man
sagte dass einzelne oder auch kochen ein
spitzensport ist nur wenn das so wäre
dann wären ja die punkte vergaben ganz
klar weil a7 und die zeit mal 1 kreise
hatten das problem ist und ist halt
immer auch noch ein bisschen ein stück
emotion dahinter das ist ja sehr schön
da darf ich sie zum schluss des
gesprächs ganz kurz fragen ein gastro
tipp von ihnen welche hinsicht
transportiert gastro tipp wo essen was
essen warum das ist schwierig das ist
schwierig aber wo ich am liebsten
hingehe auf dem markt also wenn es die
möglichkeit gibt dort wo man ist war es
ein markt hat und die hoffnung besteht
dass jemand von diesem markt sein
produkt noch zubereitet auch ganz
einfach als kasten küche dann unbedingt
dort testen weist auf frisch und so
ehrlich kriegt man das nicht wunderbar
hat ich kann nur sagen geschmack lässt
sich nicht quantifizieren lässt sich
auch nicht den preis ausdrücken und das
heißt auch nicht dass die teuersten
gewichtige besten sind sondern meine
mutter machte die besten care spitze
dieser welt das war nichts aus mehl
wasser und ein bisschen care situationen
salz und ich kann nur jedem sagen also
wer so eine kombination hat die einfach
gerne ist das soll dabei bleiben und
soll möglich schauen dass es eben die
produkte aus der gegend sind und damit
dass ich glaube den größten gefallen
auch wenn er nicht das alles drumherum
nicht jeden tag haben muss vielen
herzlichen dank für das gespräch
auch nächste woche geht es hier um ein
thema das uns alle angeht nämlich um
ängste meine kollegin barbara bleisch
spricht mit den renommierten psychiater
und angstforscher borwin bandelow über
unsere ängstliche gesellschaft über die
angst vor dem versagen vor dem leben und
vor dem unbekannten
das sollten sie nicht verpassen
[Musik]